I have good ideas but I have trouble
executing do you have any tips I have
good ideas but I have trouble executing
do you have any tips oh yeah you have
some good ideas do you but you can't
execute you you want to know what those
are those ideas are worth when you don't
execute on them you know what those
ideas are worth they're worth nothing
ideas by themselves have zero value
unless they can be brought to life and I
have known plenty of people with plenty
of ideas over the years great ideas
amazing ideas but very few people can
actually turn ideas into action
and those people end up old and bitter
and angry because they didn't execute
their great ideas and so here's what you
do you execute you actually make things
happen and sometimes I'm gonna tell you
when you execute your idea it reveals
the fact that your idea isn't all that
good it's not the brilliant idea you
thought it was and some people are
actually afraid of that and that's what
stops them but I'm not afraid I say but
bring on that failure let me learn that
my idea is no good because even if you
learned that your idea is garbage at
least you know not to waste any more
time dreaming about it or thinking about
it go on to your next idea but don't let
these ideas just wander aimlessly around
in your head get them out bring them to
life put them
to the world run with them and get some
friends and family or partners someone
to help you maybe get some people that
are better at execution than you are and
give them some ownership give away those
ideas it's better to give away those
ideas then let them rot inside your head
and die and whatever path you take
whether you force yourself to execute or
you bring people in to help you whatever
path you're gonna take do it do it or
some life into your idea and like I said
you've got to remember that there's no
guarantee that when you pour life into
idea into an idea there's no guarantee
that that idea is gonna come to life -
you might pour everything you've got to
that idea and it can still die and you
might have to let it die you have to let
the dream die because some ideas aren't
good enough to live that's just the way
it is but but you know what at least
give it a chance
don't let that idea die inside your head
no more waiting no more putting it off
or waiting for the right time or the
right people or the right alignment of
things in the world no more of that no
more excuses just execution just go and
make it happen